[Music]
[Applause]
nobody goes toe to toe with bill
belichick like our good buddy tom curran
does
patriots insider nbc sports boston
here's a little sample of tom curran and
uh coach belichick
do you have to announce who your
starting quarterback is to the world
and is there an advantage in your
preparation if your opponent doesn't
know
yeah again i would just say tom that
what we're going to do is what we feel
is best for our football team and that's
what it'll be
yeah and what up your best team to keep
that under wraps
what would it be best for the team to
know
what the situation is at certain
positions
yep
okay
tom can you break down that exchange
with bill belichick what did we learn
from that exchange
i thought we learned a little bit i
thought look we understand that he is
the king of subterfuge and i figured
he'd pull it out and pull it out and
pull it out and then you know he'd have
both guys standing on the sidelines
sunday before the dolphins game
one would take a step and then the other
would run out but now he has unveiled
that it's important for the rest of the
team to know which
in thinking about it i guess it is
they've been working at it for a month
but for the last six weeks he's been
saying basically how can you ask this
question cam's my starter and then he's
asked
and then he didn't answer that
is
is there what's what's changed do you
think if anything with belichick
a couple of things have
really been kind of under reported or
highlighted the first time he said cam's
our starter
within 90 seconds it was added
that to blow cam out of that spot
somebody has to play better
at the beginning of camp again he said
you know i answered that question before
kim's our starter
and when pressed
he said but everybody has to establish a
level so he's walked it back in terms of
saying look they're all competing and in
this competition it's mac jones has not
won by a little bit it's not been a draw
it's been kind of a landslide in
performance and workload
are you more
pro-mac jones or more anti-cam newton
more pro-mac jones look cam has been
probably 30 or 40 percent better than he
looked last year the velocity on his
throws his command
of the offense and decisiveness are
miles ahead of where they were he's
never going to be what you look at and
say that's how you want to throw the
football i mean he steps left throws
right
looks weird the
ball's down here and he's not accurate
but he's been way way better and he
brings to your team something in short
yardage is a running back 12 touchdowns
last year 600 yards rushing but matt
jones makes the offense look so much
like it looked
when tom brady was running it
or even jimmy garoppolo was running it
so to me that's what they want to be and
who they want to be
who gives you a better chance to win
this year between those two
mac jones it's passing league okay he's
a very good passer and you need somebody
to maximize the skills of guys like
agalor hunter henry johnny smith all
these people the patriots spent so much
money 160 million dollars in guaranteed
money to to bring in
you need somebody to maximize that and
kim just really isn't in a position to
do that at his age
when you go back to draft night and
there's a lot of revisionist history
here where you know oh yeah you know
patriots knew that he was going to be
another tom brady or i think we weren't
sure if he was going to the san
francisco 49ers and then when we
realized they were taking trey lance
then it was like boy he's going to start
falling
why didn't some of these other teams
pick him up
like what did belichick see in him or
josh mcdaniels that carolina didn't or
chicago didn't or somebody trading up to
get a quarterback
i think ceiling
the ceiling that you perceive for a
player like mack jones who doesn't have
that
electric athleticism that justin fields
has
or
obviously a trey lance has
so the floor is extremely high and
belichick saw something that could say
okay we can win with this guy and we
we know that this coaching staff is
extremely confident in its ability to
coach players up get the most out of
them and also win in game situations by
being smarter
so they're not
really infatuated with the notion of
that
quarterback
who is an outlier and can do things
nobody else can do they just want
somebody to run the system and jones can
do that that doesn't appeal i think
perhaps to chicago look i like justin
fields better than mac jones as a draft
pick
probably because i thought he could do
more things and i didn't think that
jones was going to be this good thought
he was a byproduct of the system
and
throwing to first round level players
against college kids i said it's not
it's not even
but he's been way better than i thought
but also being the right quarterback for
the right system justin fields
you know wouldn't have been the right
quarterback probably for this system
in the same way cam isn't yeah and
that's why it's square peg round hole
how long are we gonna carry this out
which is what's fascinating right now
because
you know they they have to make a
decision on it and where cam goes
mentally
if he's told look you're not the starter
is a fascinating part of this too
because i think the patriots value him
and won him around
also local sentiment i imagine patriot
fans this is your homegrown player cam
is a rental plus hey we can get back to
where we were because now we've got a
young tom brady clone with that
fair assessment
completely and who's only going to get
better so if your argument is
all right well matt jones is too raw
and my buddy phil perry who's on the
beat with me at nbc sports boston
continually points out that when you
have a rookie quarterback
who can play
it's
the most economically advantageous
position you can be in
because in four years you're going to be
giving them the kind of contract if he's
good that mahomes or josh allen or
dak prescott ends up garnering but right
now you want to maximize the amount of
time that players on the field because
it's actually a win for you against the
salary cap so get him started so that to
me is an interesting aspect of this too
when does belichick make the uh
long-anticipated announcement i hope
it's
saturday because i have a bet with
michael felger up here
that uh he won't announce it before the
end of business on friday
felger thinks it'll be
by friday into business and i have to
buy him a bottle of tequila he has to
buy me a 60 degree
lob wedge
if it comes up my way
but do you think this is a news dump
that belichick's gonna go
uh let's do this at around 505 and uh
100
yeah i i would imagine he doesn't want
to have us running around
the zoom conference's calls because
we're not in the locker room um say what
do you think
do you feel bad for cam
but what about that cam did a lot you
know obviously just fishing
and
i could see him you know and once you
get to september 5th next monday it's
prep week for the miami dolphins yeah we
already made that decision what's the
what's the one question you just you can
or topic you just can't ask belichick
about
malcolm butler
but butler might be retiring
can you bring that up to bill if malcolm
butler retires by saying
coach now that malcolm's uh retired uh
can you expound upon what happened in
the super bowl
it's certainly fair you know what else
we honestly dan we haven't asked it done
to me yesterday
and we have to ask
what's your reaction to tom brady
winning the super bowl
wait no hasn't been asked that
why
we just
i guess the train left the station and
we forgot we left that piece of luggage
on the on the platform that that's
are you even asking are you afraid
now now that i thought of it no but this
has to be the right time i can't spit it
out when he's talking about cuts
okay i'm gonna be belichick let's
practice this and you uh you're gonna
ask me
okay all right uh
bill i don't know if you noticed but uh
back in february one of your former
players
tom brady
was able to secure a super bowl with now
that's a player that you kind of pushed
toward the door for about three years
and
um seemingly felt as if he wasn't able
to perform he wanted to stay here bill
he would have preferred to stay here but
now that he's gone and threw 40
touchdowns and
4633 yards and and won another super
bowl d do you feel like that you're in a
situation now we want him back
no
that's not the way to do it no
that's just his answer is no
no right yeah
yeah and there is no more adept there's
no more adept interviewer
in american
journalism than you what would how would
you ask it
how would you broach the topic
uh
did how much of the super bowl did you
watch coach
i had a lot going on i was barbados
what was your reaction when you found
out tom and gronk won a super bowl
that's the first time i'm hearing of it
right now
[Laughter]
like he can shut you down no matter what
your question is
but
like you were building it up and you got
cute don't know if you noticed one of
your forms no i know i wouldn't do it
yeah
yeah so you just go
you have to just see if he wants to talk
about it what was your reaction to tom
and gronk put gronk in there too
uh just because then it doesn't become
you and you against brady so you put
gronk in there and then maybe
he gives you a little bit
i mean it just depends on if he wants to
give you something or not you know how
it is where you go yeah honestly the
best mode of attack would be bill as we
continue to watch the quarterback
situation unfold here
do you ever look in retrospect and say
maybe
it would have been a good idea to keep
tom brady
given his accomplishments in tampa bay
no
see he's not you're giving him the
opportunity to say
no
how stupid was it
[Laughter]
from from one to two no because you
can't even say one to ten uh uh coach
how stupid was it uh on scale one to ten
that uh you guys didn't think tom had
anything left in the tech
oh
uh we done yeah
yeah
that's it because i ordered my coffee do
you do
donkeys or starbucks
but you live in massachusetts you guys
you know dunkin donuts but do you do the
app and so you get there and it's ready
yeah yeah
yeah drivers apps you sit in the
drive-through
out onto the street in my neighborhood
out onto the street they're sitting in
the drive-through
well sometimes if i see there's a long
line then i just walk in and say hello
to people i'm a man of the people wait a
minute but you don't use the app to
order your coffee yeah
you know okay yeah so it's all it's
ready for me whether i go through the
drive-through or i walk in to the store
we have the drive-through here is so
there's there's never less than seven
cars in it and i'm a i'm a two-car
drive-through guys i see two i'm going
in yeah i'm there with you
but you know sometimes i want to make
somebody's day and then go into
starbucks and say hello to people
well here comes that guy who thinks he's
the mayor here coming in again
did you realize that i had to go through
four months where i had purified water
and steamed vegetables when i had my
health issues so i couldn't go to
starbucks
but i would drive through the starbucks
drive-thru
and i didn't order i just drove through
and i said hello to the people
and then i would drive up to the window
and i would just wave i didn't pick up
anything
that's pretty sad
it is and you know that the baristas
would just go weirdest guy ever yeah
that is the weird we have the weirdest
guy ever in our town yeah i actually
would disguise my voice
and then
my daughter said dad there's a camera
they can see you but i would go up there
and say uh yes i i would like to have i
like gilbert godfrey i'd like to have a
you know
and then they go okay dan and then i go
oh okay and then the next time i try to
disguise my voice again
i'm back on the starbucks train though
just let you know i can tell yeah
they must be so they must be so relieved
yes they are yes they are uh good luck
today and we wait for the tom brady
question
for bill belichick i'll i'll let you
know what i'm going to unveil it i'll
let you know all right thanks bud see
you guys that's tom curran patriots
insider nbc sports boston
bring in tom curran the um nbc sports
boston patriots outsider apparently you
were an insider a couple hours ago but
cam gets released what happened here
well i i told you that matt jones was
going to be the starter
what do you mean outsider yeah but did
you know that cam would be released i
didn't know how things would come to
pass but i mean i'm telling you out here
that that mac i mean i'm telling you i
mean dan i'm on it
i said mack jones is going to be the
starter now whatever kim's reaction was
to that i consumed it probably wasn't
that positive because he is now
no longer a new england patriot but i
just think it's an interesting
development
to me and
i don't know which is more interesting
the fact that they let him go
or he has to be let go
or the fact that they've gone with a
rookie quarterback probably the latter
yeah i i never thought bill would go
with the rookie quarterback just didn't
but yeah i mean he he obviously
loves what he sees but i i'm guessing
cam
being familiar with his ego he's
probably going you're not cutting me
uh
you know i'm going to ask for my release
sure i know it's semantics here but can
he
i don't even know if somebody's going to
be interested in cam because he didn't
have any offers
until the patriots scooped him up yeah
and i mean here's the thing he's an
unvaccinated player
who
is not an accurate thrower who plays a
unique style of quarterback that needs a
certain set of
factors in place to make him his most
successful so i think it could be a
little bit of time before he hooks on
with somebody
you know
as i said you know in a column yesterday
and today don't be so sure the cam's
going to be the starter because when you
look at matt jones's workload
compared to cams they were not preparing
cam newton to start the season he had
two drives against the giants he had two
drives against the eagles he missed five
days last week um there's been very few
days if any when he's out played mack
jones
so the only reason that people were
clinging to the idea that kim would
start
was the fact that he was starting
pre-season games but that's largely
symbolic to me
well i also think and you bring up some
great points here that i don't know if
those five days that he missed and mac
jones was taking you know all the the
reps with the the number ones there what
he was doing in games like it he never
felt like he was overwhelmed in with any
of this
um
but do you think not being vaccinated
played any role in in cam newton being
released by the patriots
i know the patriots want their players
to be vaccinated period
and i think that last week's occurrence
even on a minor technicality not a
closed contact not a positive test none
of that missing a test
amplified for them the tenuousness of
his availability so certainly that has
to weigh into it whether that's number
five number three number nine absolutely
every single player is going to be
evaluated on vaccination status
he's tom curran patriots insider
who told us a couple of days ago that
mack jones should be the starter and you
know
you got your wish
i didn't care dan i'm just trying to
chronicle the team you know
okay
all right i mean what's your what's your
first question for belichick when you
see him hey bill are you as excited as i
am
this is what i wanted
no i just did no
two appearances one show i think the
vaccination status is not a horrible
question because it
it absolutely is a factor absolutely
i don't i i good luck asking the
question
it should be is mac jones vaccinated
we can only go on
without confirmation from him which he
didn't provide we can only go on the
signs which are he walks around unmasked
so i'm guessing that he is vaccinated
all right uh thank you again tom
bye dan yeah
we'll we'll call you next hour oh that's
right we're not on next time
yep that's two two appearances tom kern
nfl insider for the patriots patriots
insider